- You have to, I believe,
let small, bad things happen
constantly to have any agenda of your own,
and to get the big, positive things done.
And if you're like, I don't have time,
I can't sleep, I need
to cut back on sleep,
I need to do this, I need to do that,
if you don't have time,
you don't have priorities.
That's it.
Perfection is achieved not when
there's nothing more to add,
but when there's nothing
more to take away.
- He's an American author,
entrepreneur, and public speaker.
He's written a number of self-help books
on the Four-Hour theme.
He's also a successful angel investor.
He's Tim Ferriss, and
here's my take on his
Top Ten Rules for Success, Volume 2.
Rule number six is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired, as well,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you, as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat theme music)
- I find that levels of success
in almost any industry or area
correlate to a person
asking great questions.
In some cases, they seem absurd.
In fact, the hallmark, in
a way, of great questions
is they sound completely ridiculous.
So someone might ask, like
Peter Thiel, why can't you
achieve your 10-year goals
in the next six months?
As a thought exercise,
that's a good question
to answer for yourself.
And these types of questions
come up surprisingly often
with very, very impressive
folks, whether it's in business,
military, entertainment, or otherwise.
And the way you can get
better at questions is by
studying interviews, in part.
So I studied Larry King.
I studied Charlie Rose.
I studied Terry Gross.
I studied da, da, da,
da, go down the list.
I studied Tony Robbins,
who does in-person,
one-on-one interventions at his events
in front of 10,000, 5,000 people,
and he's just genius with
how he uses questions
to pattern-interrupt and
grab someone's attention,
and divert them in a more
productive direction.
Now, why is that relevant?
It's relevant because
thinking is the process
of asking questions.
You're asking yourself questions,
and then you're answering
them in your own head.
So if you get better at
asking other people questions,
you get better at asking
yourself questions,
which means you are improving
your thought performance
and level of thinking.
When I'm procrastinating
because there's indecision,
and this is a particular
breed of procrastination,
in other words, if I have
10 things on my to-do list,
or 10 potential projects I could pursue,
what to do in that situation?
And what I ask myself is,
which one of these, if done,
will make the rest irrelevant or easier?
This is a key question I ask all the time.
Which one of these will make
all the rest easier to do,
if done first, or, all of
the rest of them irrelevant,
don't even need to do them.
That is how I will then hone
in on one piece of the puzzle.
And this can be applied
all over the place.
But let's just say it's
the developing a podcast.
It could be losing weight, all right?
You can see that's very, very amorphous,
when you need timelines, when
you need an amount to lose.
And then you want to make
it as small as possible.
So I'll give you a different example.
If you want to start flossing your teeth,
who likes flossing their teeth?
Pretty much nobody.
So how do you start flossing your teeth?
Well, you want to make
it as easy as possible
to develop as part of
your routine, to make it
as automatic as anything else
that you do consistently.
You can borrow from, say, BJ Fogg,
who's done a lot of research
at Stanford and elsewhere,
make it as small as possible,
meaning, in the beginning,
do less than you are capable of doing.
This is another key.
When you think something
is too big or onerous,
so it's too intimidating,
or it's too much of a pain in the ass.
So for flossing, you might say,
I'm only going to floss
my front two teeth.
That's three gaps. That's
all you're going to do.
And you want to make it,
again, as easy as possible.
So you might use a Water Pik.
Or you might use those
disposable flossing gadgets
so you don't have to do
tourniquets on your fingers,
which is also one of the
side effects of flossing
that deters people.
Make it as easy as possible.
Now this applies to a
lot more than flossing.
I've talked to many of the people
for, say, Tools of Titans,
people who are eight-time New York Times
best-selling authors,
or prolific musicians,
prolific music producers like Rick Rubin,
who's legendary.
And it all comes down to
tiny homework assignments.
So Rick, if he has a stuck
artist, for instance,
he will say, can you get
me one word or one line
that you might like for this
song that you're working on,
by tomorrow?
Is that possible?
Mini, mini homework
assignments, all right?
So with a creative project,
in the beginning, that's one.
It's related to a piece
of advice that I got
from Neil Strauss,
eight-time New York Times
best-selling author.
He has written for the New York Times.
He's written for Rolling Stone magazine.
And that is, lower your standards.
He doesn't believe in writer's block.
He says, your standards are just too high.
You're creating performance
anxiety for yourself.
So the advice that I
got from another writer,
which matches with that, is
two crappy pages per day.
So a lot of people are
like, I'm going to kill it.
I need an ambitious goal.
Let me do 1,500 words, 2,000 words per day
for this book I'm working on.
Well, there is a very high probability
that you're going to fall short of that,
and then you will get demoralized,
then you will get intimidated by the task,
and then you will start procrastinating.
So make the hurdle, make
the success threshold
really, really low.
That's what I've done
for my last three books,
is two crappy pages per day.
That's all I need.
If I don't end up using them, that's fine.
I just need to get out two crappy pages.
What ends up happening, with the flossing,
with the writing, with, say, exercise?
If you're going to exercise,
you're making a New Year's
resolution, don't make it an
hour a day, four times a week.
No, no, no, no, no.
And if you don't have an exercise habit,
five to 10 minutes at the gym,
three times a week, plenty.
And in all those cases,
you will feel successful,
because you've checked
your box for success,
and then, very often,
you will exceed that
for extra credit, right?
Well, I'm already at the gym,
I'll go for an extra 10 minutes.
Well, I'm already flossing my teeth,
I'll do an extra four.
Well, I've already hit my two pages,
but I'm feeling great and I'm in the flow.
Maybe I'll do 10, maybe I'll do 20.
But it prevents you from
feeling like a failure.
This is very, very important.
That is what derails a lot of people.
And it also makes the
task less intimidating.
It's easy to discard,
say, 10 terrible ideas
and go after the one good idea,
but when you start to get
a little bit of momentum,
you can drown yourself
in good opportunities
that aren't great opportunities.
And if you scatter your focus,
you try to do 17 different product lines,
you can kill your business really easily,
particularly when you have a small team.
So I think asking yourself, repeatedly,
what is the one project,
the one initiative,
the one campaign that, if successful,
will render the rest of these
things either unnecessary
or much, much easier?
What is that one step?
And I've called it this
lead domino before,
but what is the one thing on this list
of seven different
campaigns that will make
all the other ones
irrelevant or much easier?
- That's a tough answer, isn't it?
Because they all sound good.
- Yeah, I think they can.
And I think that what it
comes down to, oftentimes is,
it returns back to measurement.
So how are we defining success?
If we want to grow the
company, let's just say,
what does that mean?
In three months, six months,
what are we measuring?
Why are we measuring those things?
And what is a sort of
comfort goal, meaning,
okay, we think we can
easily hit this number.
What is a stretch and what is, like,
hallelujah, we threaded the needle?
And then come up with a really
concrete number to tackle.
Once you have that number,
then you can look at those
five and say, all right,
which of those are going
to serve us right now?
And I'm dealing with
that, increasingly so,
because I have all
these different branches
of content and activities and
angel investing and so on.
It's very easy for me to get scattered.
It's never been easier.
So I have to continually
ask that type of question.
- What's your main focus now?
If you had to boil it down to one?
- My main focus right now is
building my podcast, the Tim Ferriss Show,
up to a point where it's consistently
in the top 10 to 15 on iTunes,
so that I can establish a
presence and name recognition
in Hollywood in entertainment,
which I can leverage, then,
for the TV show and film
projects that I'll be
expanding into in the
next three to nine months.
And specifically what that
means is, targeted advertising
for the podcast,
specifically towards people
who are producers,
agents, actors, directors
in Hollywood and New York City.
All of that can be quantified.
- [Woman] Timothy, how do I
get a four-hour work week?
Is that possible?
- The four-hour work week is possible,
but you need to completely
unplug and reset.
And the reason that's
necessary is because there is
an epidemic, and I do mean
epidemic in this country,
of information abuse and
information addiction,
where people have come to believe that
checking email 200 times per day,
having a Blackberry to
your head or in your hand
while you're at dinner or on the subway
or in your car or with your friends,
is the path to becoming more
productive and more successful.
- [Woman] You mean, it isn't?
- It isn't, because
giving everyone around you
every person in the world
immediate access to you
is inviting interruption
and inviting minutia
to completely invade your life,
which is happening to everyone.
- [Woman] Did it happen to you?
- It did happen to me.
I had no intention of writing this book,
but from 2000 to 2004,
I was working at startups
in Silicon Valley.
I started my own, I was the CEO,
and I worked from 7:00 AM to 9:00 PM.
Every day, I checked
Outlook, hitting Send/Receive
100 to 200 times per day,
like a rat with a
cocaine pellet dispenser.
Slept under my cubicle.
Sent emails on Thanksgiving to prospects.
It was a depressing scene.
And it's a very,
unfortunately, common scene.
And I think everyone is
at a point of overwhelm.
There is more information
than we can possibly organize.
Time management is dead.
- [Woman] Well, how do
you turn that around?
- The way to turn it around is,
you have to completely unplug and reset.
That means you need to take a step back.
Forget about what people expect you to do.
Forget about what's
popular, and really look
at what works and what
is consuming your time.
There are four steps.
There's definition, elimination,
automation, and liberation.
Definition is simple.
First, you need to define
your ideal lifestyle.
What do you want to be
doing from when you wake up
to when you go to sleep?
What do you want to have?
What do you want to be?
What do you want to do?
And how much does that
ideal lifestyle cost?
And that becomes your target.
Elimination is simple.
It's getting rid of
everything, all the static,
all the noise, all the interruptions,
all the micromanaging,
all the people possible
that interfere with getting
into that ideal lifestyle.
The third, automation,
is about taking the few
remaining tasks that are
important but time-consuming,
and either delegating, automating,
or somehow outsourcing them.
In my particular case, I have
an army of MBAs in India,
about 25 of them who
work for $4.00 an hour,
and take care of tasks
that otherwise consume
hundreds of my hours.
And then the last step, liberation,
is about the final ingredient
in lifestyle design,
which is mobility, and then also,
how to use the time once you create it,
which is very difficult for most people.
- [Woman] Okay, this is
fascinating, but that's the point.
It is difficult.
How do you put the Blackberry down?
Aren't you worried that
you're not going to make
as much money, that you're
going to lose clients?
Do you have statistics that show that
that's not the case?
- I have statistics that would absolutely
make your head spin.
If you're interrupted by email and phone,
there was an experiment done
at Kings College, for example,
that showed that people who were stoned
scored six points better on an IQ test
than people who were
interrupted by email and phone.
- [Woman] Wow.
Good to know.
- Good to know, 26 percent
of people in the American
workforce are on the verge
of a nervous breakdown.
The system is not working.
It's not a question of,
if I should do this.
It's a question of when.
It is the only real alternative.
One simple step that people
can take, a baby step,
to prove the concept, is to
simply use an autoresponder.
Set up an autoresponder that
tells everyone who emails you,
I will be checking email twice a day.
- [Woman] That's a great idea.
- At 11:00 and 4:00 PM.
If you require a more
urgent response before
one of those two times,
call me on my cell phone.
- [Woman] Okay, if I
start losing customers,
I'm going to call you, Tim.
- You can call me.
- Okay?
- What's going to happen,
instead of losing customers,
you'll get more done in the next 48 hours
than you would in the next two weeks.
- In a world where people
expect immediate responses,
oftentimes, and increasingly
so, you have to, I believe,
let small, bad things happen, constantly,
to have any agenda of your own,
and to get the big, positive things done.
It's recognizing that to
prevent all hurt feelings,
all mistakes, all problems,
all of this is impossible.
And if you try to do that,
you'll never have a proactive
schedule of your own,
is extremely important.
So, effectively, just
saying I'm going to accept
the collateral damage
and believe that what I'm embarking upon
is worth more than those
minor or reversible problems.
And then forging ahead.
That's it. You got to
take a few flesh wounds.
The five-minute journal is,
it's a journal that
was created by a reader
of The Four-Hour Work Week, actually,
for those who have read the book.
It was their muse, so one
of their cash-flow focused
businesses in the concept
of lifestyle design, but
you take two and a half
minutes, or so, in the morning
and then again at night.
So one is, effectively, a
focusing and planning exercise.
There's also a gratitude component,
which I think is very critical
for those of us who are
driven, Type A, achievers.
It's very easy to constantly
be focused on the future.
And just to hit pause for a second,
I heard someone say that depression is
an obsession with the past,
and anxiety is an
obsession with the future.
Well, if you look at achievers,
they tend to be very future-focused.
And as soon as they hit
a goal, they're like,
don't have time to
celebrate this small win.
This isn't good enough, bigger,
bigger, better, et cetera.
That is a pattern that can
be very self destructive,
even if you rack up a lot
of wins at the same time.
So the gratitude component
is extremely critical.
That takes about two and
a half minutes each day,
and it also helps to
identify your focal points
or your priorities so
that when, inevitably,
that 10 percent that's left
of the monkey mind pops up
to dance in front of you and distract you
from your objectives
you set out for the day,
you can return to that.
And then, at the end of the day,
it's basically a performance review.
I find it incredibly helpful, and
a lot of ROI for the time invested.
Large, uninterrupted blocks of time.
You have to schedule,
if you are a creator,
blocks of time that are,
at least, two to four hours
or more in length.
No Frankentstein monster
of 20-minute breaks
and 10-minute breaks
combined into three hours
will have the value of
an uninterrupted block
of three hours.
If you are trying to make
high-level decisions,
focus on time-consuming,
high-priority projects,
push something to a next milestone,
as a maker/creator.
We all have the same 24 hours in a day
and if you're like, I don't have time,
I can't sleep, I need
to cut back on sleep,
I need to do this, I need to do that,
if you don't have time,
you don't have priorities.
That's it.
- Are you one of those entrepreneurs who
likes to launch very early with a product
which is not finished and get
as much feedback as you can,
or are you, the other school is more like,
you do it in secret, and you
test, do the market research,
you do everything in secret and you launch
when you consider it's really good?
- I think that you can do both, actually.
I think that it's possible
to get that early feedback,
which is critical,
without making it public,
in the sense that,
you can work even with a
small group of friends,
which is what I did with the book,
but also with some of the
startups that I'm working with,
get feedback from people
who represent different demographics,
then incorporate that into the beta,
when you make it open.
But I generally believe in fast sprints,
let's just say, two-week
development sprints.
So that might combine
with agile development,
but do two-week sprints, push
something out, get feedback.
Take a brief rest.
Do another sprint, get a few features out,
wait, get feedback.
Google also does this
on a fairly large scale.
When they launched
Google News, for example,
they were wondering
whether they should sort by
location or date, and there
were a few other variables.
They decided that they would push it out
and simply see how many requests
and complaints they got,
related to each of those features.
And almost no one asked for location.
Most of them asked for dates.
So that's the feature
that they built into it
in the next iteration.
So I believe in microtesting.
I'd say that's generally my approach.
Keep things simple, and when
you're looking for solutions,
to try to remove things first
rather than to add things.
This is a really, really
critical principle.
And less can be more in
this particular respect,
especially for behavioral change.
This is a sign that I have
over one of my doorways
in my house, Simplify.
And above that I have
a knife. Why a knife?
Because when you make a decision,
the word decision is related to incision.
It means to cut off.
It means to cut away other options
and to commit and to focus.
And that's what I recommend all of you do
with whatever that skill is that you have
in your head still, hopefully.
Perfection is achieved not when
there's nothing more to add,
but when there's nothing
more to take away.
Let's just go to this mat here.
- [Jason] Oh wait, we got
to do it the right way.
- Ah, I was going to catch you.
- My Dutch friends (mumbles).
- So the, yeah,
this is a, so yeah,
then I lean back, then we
bring the partner down.
So apparently, the Dutch
acrobats get very upset
if you don't do that.
I've gotten to the point
where I'm like, you know what?
I've had enough of the Dutch.
I love their kickboxing,
Ernesto Hoost, love you, but.
From all the jiu jitsu,
I'm just like, flop.
I've made a lot of, I'm
not going to say enemies.
That doesn't really happen in Acro.
I am standing with my feet
reasonably close to your hips.
- I want to be able to
touch my flier's feet.
My feet are turned out
just below the hip bones.
- I am standing straight up.
It's almost as if, you've seen the UFC,
you're like open guard on your back.
This would be where I try to punch you
and then you kick me in the
face, but that's not Acro.
That's MMA.
All right, and then
flier, fingers forward.
- You got it. You got the
acronyms and everything.
- Just so people, I learned,
I'm a young Padawan. I'm
just learning what I can.
- The most important thing
is that you understand
when to be water and when to be earth,
and what parts of your body.
So I'm going to be watery with my arms,
and really sturdy with my legs.
So we'll take a deep breath.
(inhales)
On the exhale, I receive with everything
and then I push up with the legs.
Here, a lot of times, the
flier will want to put
the hands down and practice
their handstand training.
That means they're a control freak.
- [Tim] Yeah.
So you fold the top of their
hands down to the floor,
so at this point, those people listening,
I am supported on Jason's feet.
I'm completely upside down.
I'm basically in a L-straddle position,
for those of you who know
anything about gymnastics.
So this is Folded Leaf.
Sometimes, in hushed tones,
jokingly referred to as Leaf Blower.
- Oh my god, I didn't know that.
I was going to come and blog that.
- [Tim] I'm trying to help people
with the images here.
So this is Scarecrow, right?
- This is Scarecrow.
And basically what I do, as a base,
is I try to let your body unwind patterns.
So as I bounce and shake, a lot of times
our mind is connected to muscle groups,
and flexing them when
they don't need to be.
So the true therapist is gravity,
which helps to let your
spine hang like a plumb line.
- [Tim] And could we show, for instance,
let's see here, Super Yogi?
- Sure.
So Tim likes traction,
so what I can do is, I
can let my legs come off
my 90 degree.
His weight will start falling back.
We'll take a deep breath together.
(inhales)
On the exhale, my legs go back
and I resist with the arms.
It's okay?
- Mm-hmm.
- Two more, inhale.
(inhales)
Exhale, so I'm pushing the legs
back and giving resistance.
I got a little wrist action there.
One more time, inhale.
(inhales)
And exhale.
(exhales)
And then where I love to go
is to open up your triceps
and your shoulders.
So I'm going to place my
hands under his elbows.
He can bend the elbows and
the knees at the same rate.
Okay, bring the elbows closer.
Does that feel okay on your shoulder?
- [Tim] Yeah, maybe be a
little careful on the left.
- Yeah.
- [Tim] Just had it
reconstructed, but yeah.
This feels fine.
- [Jason] And in general, where
the body can be vulnerable
in the flying is in the
shoulders and the lower back,
so communication is really important,
and just listening to your body.
All good?
- All good.
- Sweet.
Side bending is also a
thing that can really help
the health of the lower back.
And what's different with
the therapeutic flying
from yoga is, your body
doesn't have to be engaged.
You're not using your
muscles as the flier,
so you don't have to
work uphill, basically.
- [Tim] All right.
- Ya mon.
So those are some basics
of therapeutic flying.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned
that blew your mind, that you're going to
immediately apply to your
life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
Also, if you want to nominate someone
for the next Top Ten video,
please check the description
for a link to a video where
you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions, as well.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to John Sonmez
from the Simple Programmer
YouTube channel.
John, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and for
making that awesome video
on your channel.
I really, really appreciate the support
and I'm glad that you enjoyed the read.
- And recently, I just had
the opportunity to read
a book that he put out,
which I just did a video review on.
- So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- For every problem,
the problem, itself,
presents an opportunity
that dwarfs the problem.
That is to say that if
I had only looked at
my failure with the audio book,
and viewed it as a failure
in the product, let's say,
and not in the process, I
wouldn't have taken away much.
Instead, I realized that
my approach wasn't right,
fixed my approach, and
that has led to a lot
of great successes.
If you get a thousand die-hard, true fans
who love your product, pay for it,
and are relatively price-insensitive,
you can always scale up from there.
If you try to aim for, as they would say,
boiling the ocean, you're
going to run out of money,
and your advertising, your marketing
will be very imprecise.
It will be designed
subconsciously or consciously
not to offend anyone, and as a result,
you will have no die-hard fans.
A lot of really good
entrepreneurs start as a
technician or tactician,
are very, very good at one thing.
Then they end up in a
managerial role that they hate.
It doesn't mean you have to stay there.
And you see a lot of folks,
like Evan Williams and others,
who then, at some point, realize this
and return to a more product-focused role,
even if they are also the CEO
making some high-level,
30,000-foot decisions.
Okay, but, if you are a maker,
if you've decided to be a maker,
if you just happen to
be a maker or a creator,
let's call it three- to
five-hour uninterrupted
blocks of time are extremely critical.
If you want to connect the dots,
if you want to have the space
to allow yourself to have original ideas,
or at least, original
combinations of ideas,
you really need to block
out that time and protect it
at least once a week.
In Tools of Titans, there
are many people who do this,
Ramit Sethi, for instance,
has a very, very successful
multi-million dollar
business that he built
out of a blog he started
long ago in college,
which was very, very niche in its focus.
He blocks out, I believe
it's every Wednesday
for three to five hours of time,
he'll block it out for learning.
Noah Kagan, another entrepreneur,
does the same thing.
So on Wednesdays, for me, I
have from 9:00 AM to 1:00 PM,
this is pre-lunch, I have Creation.
That means writing, recording,
or some similar aspect
of, in my mind, creating with
my skill set and my assets.
And it is extremely
important that I do that
before I am barraged by inputs.
In other words, and this
is true of Josh, as well,
first thing in the morning,
he's doing journaling.
Reid Hoffman, billionaire,
co-founder or founder
of LinkedIn, same story.
He will plant a seed in
his mind the night before,
a problem he wants to solve,
a project he wants to think
about improving, perhaps,
and then waking up
tabula rasa, complete blank slate,
immediately working on that
problem with journaling,
before any text messages,
before any email.
Which is why, for instance,
I don't have email
set up on my phone.
I do not have mail set up on my iPhone.
I do not get notifications.
I also put my phone on Airplane
mode, for a lot of reasons.
If you've read The Four-Hour Body,
it explains some of the physical ones.
But onto Airplane mode when I go to bed,
and it stays in Airplane
mode until I am done
with my Creation period.
And then it comes on,
because as soon as you
go into bullet-dodging
or, like Wonder Woman,
bullet blocking mode
with everyone else's agenda for your time,
which is very often the
inbox or text messages,
you're DOA, you're done.
Your creativity is all
for naught, in general.
So for me, for many people
who are, say, programming,
for musicians, for creative
types, slack in the system.
You have to create slack.
You have to create space.
You have to create large,
uninterrupted blocks of time,
and the only way to do that
is to put it on your calendar.
If it's not on your
calendar, it's not real.
You need to put it in your calendar
and defend it, just like
you would anything else.